es kann nur eine bewertung geben dass es
verfassungswidriger umsturz und auch
gewaltsamen machtergreifung
mit waffengewalt und keiner bestreitet
diese tatsache wer soll diese frage
streiten die frage für mich
wäre ich beantworten kann noch auch
meine kollegen beantworten können mit
denen wie sie wissen ich sehr viel in
der letzten zeit das problem der ukraine
telefonisch besprochen habe das ist die
frage wozu das unternommen wurde
beachten sie bitte dass der präsident
janukowitsch unter vermittlung von drei
außenminister der eu
polen deutschland und frankreich im
beisein meines
vertreters in dieser qualität war unser
bevollmächtigter für menschenrechte der
russische föderation halloween
aufgetreten
sie haben unter der opposition und der
macht am 21
februar diese vereinbarung unterzeichnet
und nach dieser beeindruckte das beton
ob das gut ist oder schlecht ich möchte
keine wertung geben nur die tatsache
janukowitsch praktisch seine macht quasi
abgegeben hat er war mit allem
einverstanden was die opposition von ihm
verlangte er war bereit mit der
vorzeitige wahl des parlaments mit der
vorzeitigen wahl des präsidenten der
bereich zur verfassung von 2004 zurück
zu kommen das verlangte die opposition
er reagierte positiv auf unsere bitte
und auch auf die bitte des westlichen
lernen dass keine gewalt eingesetzt
werden er hat doch keinen einzigen
ungesetzlichen befehl erteilt wegen
schießen auf dieser unglückseligen
demonstranten mehr noch er hat ein
befehl gegeben alle polizeikräfte aus
der hauptstadt zu entfernen und sie
haben diesen befehl erfüllt der ist dann
zu einer veranstaltung nach kiew
abgereist und kaum ist der nachhaltige
abgereist wurde sofort alles
wurden die anstelle die
verwaltungsgebäude zu räumen wurde seine
residenz erobert und das
regierungsgebäude anstelle das zu
erfüllen was vereinbart wurde warum
stelle ich diese frage ich möchte selbst
bestehen wozu das gemacht er hat doch
die macht abgegeben und ich er hatte
keine chance ich habe ihm das auch
gesagt so wiedergewählt zu werden und
eine kollegin von mir waren damit
einverstanden alle politischen müssen
und so sollte man die
verfassungswidrige handlungen
unternehmen und das land in das chaos
hinein zu stürzen indem das land jetzt
bis heute spazieren durch die stadt kiew
noch die kämpfer mit maskierter kämpfer
mit waffen in der hand was sollten
wollten sie jemand eher niedrig und die
eigene grab zeigen dass waren diese
handlungen waren absolut dumm ich glaube
das ergebnis war entgegengesetzt dem das
erwartet wurde da musste ich ihm denn
durch diese handlungen
hat man den osten praktisch in unruhe
gebracht und den süden jetzt also warum
diese situation überhaupt entstanden ist
er mir scheint das war eine
revolutionäre situation die entstand
schon seit langer zeit vom ersten tag
der erklärung der unabhängigkeit der
ukraine ein einfacher ukrainischer buer
ein einfacher mann
leidet der ukraine leidet unter dem
nikolaus dem blutigen unter kraft und
der kutscher und auch unter jungen
kommen und auch
nichts
hat sich zum besten verändert zumindest
die korruption erreichte das niveau das
wir in russland nicht mal träumen räumen
konnten also die differenzierung der
gesellschaft und die bereiche bei uns
gibt es auch die korruption das ist auch
noch viel
schlimmer das wurde sozusagen
potenz drei potenz 2 das sind alles
unglaubliche ausmaß der korruption und
im prinzip das volk wünschte
veränderungen aber man kann doch keine
ungesetzlichen veränderungen begünstigen
im postsowjetischen raum wo die
politischen konstrukte noch sehr fragil
sind die wirtschaft sehr schwach ist
muss man ausschließlich den
verfassungsmäßigen weg beschreiten
kardinale fehler wird immer sein wenn
man aus dem verfassungs rahmen
heraustritt ich verstehe die übrigens
die menschen die auf der meydan gestand
habe obwohl die keinesfalls begrüße die
tatsache selbst es der machtwechsel auf
diese art und weise aber ich verstehe er
noch diese menschen sie auf dem eis
gestanden haben die immer noch verlangen
dass einige damit dass
nicht irgendwelche
fassaden reparaturen durchgeführt werden
sondern cardinale veränderungen
anstreben warum verlangen sie diese
veränderungen weil sie gewöhnt sind die
einen hochstapler werden durch andere
gauner ersetzt und mehr noch die
menschen in den regionen beteiligen sich
gar nicht an der gestaltung der
regionalmacht wir hatten auch mal eine
sei dass wir die regionalen führer ein
tier macht gebracht haben indem der
präsident die an vorgeschlagen hat aber
die lokalen behörden haben die bestätigt
aber das ist jetzt so die sind jetzt
dort sieht es absolut nicht danach aus
die östliche region in den östlichen
regionen wurden oligarchen und
milliardärs die menschen akzeptieren das
nicht wir sind der meinung dass durch
die unehrliche privatisierung sowie bei
uns auf viele der meinung sind dass ihr
durch die unehrliche und die sich
bereichert haben und jetzt auch noch
dazu wir hatten sie noch an der macht
stehen in nicole peters zum beispiel
hier kann man ski wurde ja zum
gouverneur
das ist doch ein stapler ohne ende der
hat noch unseren oligarchen abramowitsch
übers ohr gehauen vor zwei jahren bei
uns sagt man in den so wie man der wurde
sozusagen geprellt dass er sagt man bei
uns unter den intellektuellen es wurde
ein vertrag abgeschlossen
karanovic hat dem einige milliarden
dollar überwiesen und er hat das geld
einfach sich in die tasche gelegt und
adieu einfach als ich ihn fragte denn
abraham ob ich warum er das gemacht hat
das sagte ich das konnte mir überhaupt
gar nicht einfallen dass so etwas
möglich ich weiß nicht ob er sein geld
zurück bekommen hat oder ob das jetzt so
geblieben ist aber das war etwa vor 23
jahren das war eine tatsächliche
situation
im leben war und ein solcher gauner
wird zum gouverneur des gebiets die
petrus gemacht natürlich sind menschen
unzufrieden sie waren unzufrieden und
sie bleiben unzufrieden wenn diese die
sich als legale macht bezeichnet weiter
so handeln und das wichtigste die
menschen müssen das recht haben das
eigene schüssel schicksal zu bestimmen
das eigene schicksal das schicksal seine
regionen und der familie und auch
gleichberechtigt unabhängig davon wo der
mensch wo und in welchen ecken des
landes ein mensch wohnhaft es er soll
gleichberechtigt seien bei der
bestimmung seines schicksals jetzt die
zweite frage ob die jetzigen macht
legitim sind ja parlament das parlament
zum teil ja die andere nicht und schon
erst recht kann man nicht über die
legitimität des amtierenden präsidenten
sprechen es gibt juristisch nur ein
einziger legitimer präsident natürlich
der hat hier keine macht aber darüber
habe ich schon gesprochen ich möchte
nochmals wiederholen dieser legitime
präsident
rein juristisch ist natürlich nur
janukowitsch es gibt drei wege nach dem
gesetz der ukraine einen präsidenten zu
entfernen der tod
sein
persönlicher machtverzicht und der tritt
als entdeckungsverfahren und das
amtsenthebungsverfahren
ist in der verfassung genau
festgelegt es soll auch das
verfassungsgericht dabei involviert sein
das parlament das ist eine ganz lange
prozedur und diese prozedur fand nicht
statt deshalb aus juristischer sicht ist
das eine unbestrittene tatsache und ich
glaube auch aus diesem grund diese
sogenannte macht wollen das
verfassungsgericht haben beschlossen ist
das verfassungsgericht auseinander zu
jagen das passt gar nicht in keine
rahmen gesetzliche weder die ukraine
noch von europa und die haben nicht nur
das verfassungsgericht und rechtmäßig
aufgelöst dann überlegen ist sie haben
den auftrag erteilt überlegen dass man
den auftrag der greift das erweiterte
sollen strafverfahren gegen die
mitglieder des verfassungsgerichtes
einzuleiten was ist es ist es etwa
freiheit gerichtswesen wie kann man
jemanden beauftragen strafverfahren
einzuleiten
wenn ihr gewicht rechtsverstöße da sind
irgendwelche verbrechen dann müssen die
rechtsorgane selbst regieren aber ein
auftrag das sind doch stiefel sozusagen
gebraten
für unsere komisch krümmung jetzt so
finanziert die halbinsel krim wissen sie
wir haben einen beschluss gefasst dass
die arbeit der regionen der russischen
föderation zur unterstützung der krim zu
organisieren sie halbinsel krim band er
sich an uns mit der bitte um diese hilfe
und wir tun das war wie welche quellen
eingesetzt werden die regierung
beschäftigen sich damit beschäftigt sich
damit es werden auch die die
randregionen dabei einbezogen aber das
werden wir ganz sicher nicht machen
jetzt über die einführung der
truppeneinsatz der militärischen bisher
es besteht keine solche notwendigkeit
aber es gibt eine solche möglichkeit
übers ich möchte von vornherein sagen
dass unsere manöver die vor kurzem
durchgeführt wurden die waren in keinem
standen in keinem zusammenhang mit den
ereignissen in der ukraine diese
maßnahme wurde schon früher geplant aber
wir haben das nicht laut bekannt gemacht
weil das eine plötzliche prüfung von der
kampfbereitschaft von militärischen
einheiten aber es wurde schon seit
langem geplant der verteidigungsminister
hat schon mir dass es seit langer zeit
gesagt und ich habe ein entsprechendes
verordnung unterschrieben diese manöver
sind zu ende gegangen wie sie wissen und
ich habe gestern den befehl arbeit alle
militärischen einheiten ihnen ihre
ständigen stützpunkte zurückzubeordern
was kann ein anlass vorwand sein um die
militärische kräfte einzusetzen dass es
natürlich im äußersten fall erstes über
die legitimität wie sie wissen wir haben
einen direkten die direkte sozusagen
anfrage des legitimen präsidenten über
die anwendung der streitkräfte zum
schutz des lebens der freiheit und der
gesundheit der bürger der ukraine
was was beunruhigt das ist die
entfesselung der aktion der neonazis
antisemiten und
nationalisten die zurzeit eben im gange
sind in manchen teilen der ukraine und
einschließlich auch der stadt hier
sie haben doch vertreter der
massenmedien gesehen wie einer der
amtierende gouverneur auf dem platz an
gefesselt wurde an irgendwelche
stirn im winter und dann hat man ihn mit
kaltem wasser übergossen und dann wurde
im keller geworfen und dort gefoltert
was soll das sein
das studium ist also soll das etwa
demokratie sein ist das etwa die
äußerung der demokratie sein er wurde
übrigens erst vor kurzem etwa im
dezember wenn man davon ausgeht dass die
leute groß sind er hatte ja quasi keine
zeit etwas zu klauen und dann wurden die
gebäude der partei der regionen
überwältigt über uns aber überhaupt
keine es kam nur da kleine mitarbeiter
ein ingenieur und noch da war das
gebäude war leer der ingenieur sagte
lassen sie doch die frauen rausgehen ich
bin ingenieur ich habe überhaupt keinen
bezug zur politik und sofort wurde er
erschossen vor den augen der menge dann
noch einer wo das sozusagen im keller
eingesperrt und mit molotow-cocktails
zugeworfen und am lebendigen leibe
verbrannt ist es etwa die äußerung der
demokratie wenn wir so etwas sehen dann
verstehen wir was die bürger der ukraine
bewegt sowohl die russin als auch die
ukraine über russischsprachige
bevölkerung
wohnt in östlichen und südlichen gegen
die ukraine was beruhigt diese
schrankenlosigkeit gesetzlosigkeit und
wenn wir sehen dass das auch beginnt in
östlichen regionen wenn uns jemand um
hilfe bittet und die offizielle anfrage
des legitimen präsident haben wir schon
so behalten wir für uns das recht alle
uns zur verfügung stehenden mittel zum
schutz dieser bürger in anspruch zu
nehmen und wir halten das für absolut
legitim das ist die äußerste maßnahme
schwer noch was möchte ich sage wir sind
der meinung wir waren und sind und
werden der meinung sein dass die ukraine
nicht nur unser nachbar nächster nachbar
sonne unser brüderliche republik unser
benachbarte und unsere streitkräfte das
sind unsere
waffenbrüder viele kennen einander
persönlich und ich bin sicher und möchte
das betonen die
ukrainischen und
auch die russischen soldaten werden
nicht an verschiedenen seiten der
barrikaden stehen sondern die an einer
seite der barrikade stellen übrigens das
war vor nicht jetzt spreche das findet
ihr es auch immer auf der krim stadt
beachten sie doch kurz zeit dank ist
doch kein schuss gefallen kein kein
opfer ist
dort zu verzeichnen nur eine wurde da
totgetrampelt eine letzte woche was
passierte die leute kamen zu den
stützpunkten der streitkräfte und die
haben mit denen ausgemacht dass sie
sozusagen dem willen des volkes sich
unterwerfen müssen der bevölkerung die
ihr da ist es gab keine kampfhandlung
hat keiner geschossen keine einzige
schuss ist gefallen und
auf diese weise
die
gespannte situation auf der krim die im
zusammenhang mit der anwendung der
gewalt stand ist weg es verschwand und
die einzige notwendigkeit die vorhanden
war und was wir auch getan wir haben nun
den schutz unsere militärische objekte
verstärkt weil die ständig bedroht
wurden und wir haben gesehen dass da die
kämpfer aus der nationalistischen
organisationen es sich immer näher kamen
zu diesen objekten und deshalb haben wir
das getan und das war gut dass wir das
so getan haben und die haben das
rechtzeitig getan deshalb ich gehe davon
aus dass auch
im osten der ukraine steht uns nicht
müssen wir brauchen wir nicht so was
machen aber was ich jetzt sage dass
kommt nichts zu meine zuständigkeit wir
haben nicht vor uns einzumischen aber
wir sind wir meinen dass alle bürger der
ukraine unabhängig davon wo sie wohnen
hat müssen die gleichen rechte genießen
an der bei der beteiligung am leben des
landes und bei der bestimmung der
zukunft dieses landes
ja und
nämlich würde an der stelle der del die
sich für legitime macht halten ich würde
mich an deren stelle bei allen
entsprechende verfahren einzusetzen denn
gesamt nationalen mandat zur
durchführung ihrer politik außenpolitik
wirtschaftspolitik umso weniger zur
bestimmung der zukunft der ukraine
verfügen sie nicht über einen solchen
mandat jetzt die märkte
stützen jetzt was die reaktion der
märkte angeht
sie wissen ja
preview die märkte wurden nervös und
zwar noch bevor es zu der verschärfung
der situation in der ukraine kam dass es
verbunden mit der politik der
vereinigten staaten die bestimmte
entscheidungen getroffen hat und das hat
also hat die investition in die
wirtschaft der usa sehr attraktiv
gemacht und von den entwicklungsmärkten
haben die investoren angefangen das geld
abzuziehen und in den amerikanischen
markt zu werfen das ist eine allgemeine
tendenz ist gar nicht mehr der ukraine
besonders hat darunter indien gelitten
und die anderen staaten brasilien indien
russland hat auch etwas darunter
gelitten das ist die grundsätzliche
ursache was die politik in der ukraine
ja natürlich die politik beeinflussen
das so auf den markt das geld liebt das
stille ruhe und stabilität
aber ich glaube das ist eine
vorübergehende erscheinung und
vorübergehende schöne seiten bitte
weitere fragen
haben sie damit gerechnet dass die
reaktion auf die handlungen russland
seitens der westlichen partner so scharf
ausfallen wird könnten sie irgendwelche
details über ihre gespräche mit den
westlichen partner uns das g8 angeht ob
es kommt jetzt die reaktion g8 und über
unsere gespräche unsere gespräche
vertraulich
manche davon ist und sogar geführt
worden sozusagen
aufgeschlossenen
telefonleitungen deswegen halte ich das
nicht für möglich dass sozusagen
zu veröffentlichen aber ich werde einige
öffentliche
erklärungen manche meine kollegen im
westen hier erwähnen ohne den namen zu
nennen was fällt uns auf es wird uns
unterstellt ihm häufig dass unser
handlungen nicht legitim waren und wenn
ich die frage stelle sind sie der
meinung etwa dass bei ihnen alles
legitim ist die beantworten ja dann muss
ich denn in erinnerung rufen die
handlungen usa in afghanistan im irak in
libyen wo sie entweder überhaupt ohne
irgendwelche sanktionen der uno
agiert haben oder diese aktion entstellt
haben die resolution wie das in libyen
war
erstellt haben und denn es gab nur die
möglichkeit luftraum zu sperren für die
für die und das endete alles mit
sozusagen
mit dem rasieren und mit den aktionen
der sondereinheiten sei der boden in
aktion unser partner insbesondere den
vereinigten staaten
die sieben immer deutlich formuliert
klar für sich ihre geopolitische und
staatliche interessen formulieren
priestley und verfolgen diese interessen
ganz hartnäckig und anschließend
die leiten sich durch eine satz wer
nicht mit uns das gegen uns und dann
versuchen sie die restliche welt
anzupassen an sich selbst unvorsichtig
anpassen lässt der wird gepresst und so
zum schluss wird er sozusagen in die
ecke gedrängt wir gehen von etwas
anderem aus wir
gehen davon aus dass wir ganz legitim
handeln und ich hab ich bin auch immer
dafür aufgetreten dass wir das
völkerrecht beachten und halten und ich
bin der meinung auch wenn ich die
entscheidung treffe über den einsetzte
militärgewalt sowie dieser entscheidung
legitim und wir der völkerrecht
entsprechend denn wir haben doch die
bitte der des legitimen präsidenten
diesbezüglich und entsprechen unseren
verpflichtungen werden wir agieren und
das entspricht auch unseren interessen
beim schutz der menschen die wir die wie
wir meinen mit uns historisch verbunden
sind kulturell verbunden sind die
verbunden sind mit uns auch
wirtschaftlich das entspricht unseren
nationalen interessen diese menschen in
schutz zu nehmen und das ist eine
humanitäre mission wir möchten keinen
unterwerfen wurde jemand etwas zu
diktieren
aber wir natürlich wir können nicht bei
seite steht wenn wir sehen dass sie
verfolgt werden dass sie vernichtet
werden sie
drangsaliert werden wir möchten dass das
nicht stattfindet
wie bewerten sie die reaktionen des
westen auf die ereignisse in der ukraine
und die bedrohungen gegenüber russland
also austritt aus g8 und
ja
ich glaube
also wenn dieses mädchen mit ihrer
taschen musik verschwindet dann saß ich
meine
jetzt was die sanktion anbetrifft über
die folgen dieser aktion müssen ihr
erster linie diejenigen sich gedanken
machen die sie einführen wollen ich
glaube dass in einer welt wo alles eng
miteinander verbunden ist und vor jeder
von jedem abhängt so kann man natürlich
einander irgendwelchen schaden zufügen
aber dieser schaden wird gegenseitig
sein und das muss beachtet werden dass
ist erstes und zweitens und das ist
glaube ich das wichtigste
ich habe bereits unsere motive unseres
handelns dargelegt und wir sehen die
motive unser partner aus sie haben einen
verfassungswidrigen
umsturz und eine
machtergreifung mit der waffe
unterstützt haben diese menschen für
legitim erklärt und versuchen diese
menschen tun zu unterstützen übrigens in
diesem fall sind wir tolerant und wir
sind sogar bereit zu irgendwas
zusammenarbeit wir wollen doch gar nicht
die zusammenarbeit und dann brechen sie
wissen ja ich habe der regierung ein
paar tagen beauftragen durchzudenken wir
können wir kontakte fortsetzen auch mit
diesen
machthabern in kiew die wir nicht für
legitim halten damit wir weitere
beziehungen im bereich der wirtschaft
und der
anderen bereichen vor zu essen wir
halten unsere handlungen berechnet und
alle drohungen in richtung russlands
kontraproduktiv und schädlich was g8
angeht wir bereiten uns auf g8 treffen
wir werden bereit unser kollegen bei uns
zu empfangen wenn sie nicht wollen uns
zu besuchen dann dann ist eben nicht
ich möchte ja selber kontakte ich hab so
verstanden sie sind der meinung dass ein
premier der halbinsel krim aktion auf
legitimes sind sie bereit mit diesen
menschen die sich in der 4 sie haben
nicht so gehört ich habe doch
beantwortet aber ich meine ich habe
keine keine partner da gibt es ja kein
präsident in kiew mit dem ich und es
kann auch keinen partner seien bis zur
gesamt weiß jetzt was die creme
das parlament der krim oder 2010 gewählt
wenn ich mich nicht täusche
etwa im dezember 2010 wurde das
parlament
gewählt sie besteht aus 100 abgeordneten
das sind sechs parteien vertreten und
nachdem der frühere premier
zurückgetreten ist das parlament der
creme entsprechenden prozeduren und
entsprechend dem gesetz bei der sitzung
der obersten rada der krim einen neuen
premierminister gewählt natürlich ist
die bts wurden dort alle verfahren
eingehalten die vom gesetz vorgesehen
sind kein einzige verstoß gab es da aber
als vor ein paar tagen eine gruppe der
bewaffneten personen versucht hat das
gebäude der obersten rada der krim zu
stürmen und so hat das natürlich große
sorge bei den bewohner der krim
ausgelöste es entstand der eindruck dass
die krim nachdem nach dem szenario von
hier weiter geht eine serie von
terrorakten und weiter deshalb haben sie
denn ausschuss der selbstverteidigung
gegründet und alle streift er unter die
kontrolle genommen als ich gesehen habe
was die da gesamt das ist wirklich das
sind ja etliche
etliche dutzende verschiedene
gerätschaften das sind rund
22.000 streitkräfte auf der halbinsel
krim aber kurz sei dank wie ich gesagt
habe und das alles ohne ein schuss
befindet sich das in der hand des volkes
aber die personen die die die
einheiten der armee auf der krim
durchgeführt haben die uniform sieht so
aus wie die russische uniformen sind das
etwa die waren dass die russischen
soldaten schauen sie mir doch dann
passierte schon raum an wir die
uniformen aus sie können geschäft gehen
und jeden jeden jede uniform sich das
war nicht die russische waren das
russische soldat das waren die die us
angemessene kräfte der
selbstverteidigung schauen sie mal wie
gut die personen vorbereitet waren die
in der krim agierten die wurden auf den
benachbarten territorien ausgebildet
wahrscheinlich in kiew vielleicht in
anderen in polen oder vielleicht in der
ukraine es woody wurden von den
ausbildern militärischen ausbildung
ausgebildet ist lange zeit hier sind ja
es gibt ja dutzend der hundertschaften
die funktionieren mit sehr guten
logistischen verbindung haben sie
gesehen wie sie über strand
professionell wie sondern einhalten
grund haben sie warum denken sie dass
auf der krim andere schlechtere soll ich
die frage noch genauer formulieren
da haben wir uns bei der vorbereitung
der selbstverteidigungskräfte vorhalt
nein wir haben das nicht beteiligt wie
sehen sie die zukunft der krim
anschluss an russland vor hat nein der
anschluss wird und nicht
in euren augen
aussicht gestellt ich glaube nur die
personen die dort wohnen
können und dürfen ihre zukunft hier
bestimmen
zb erlaubt wurde
schon erlaubt vielen teilen der welt zu
machen so das selbstbestimmungsrecht das
verankert ist keiner hat dieses recht
aufkommen wir werden keinen zu solchen
handlungen provozieren und wir werden
solche stimmungen nicht
ich möchte betonen dass ich bin der
meinung dass alleine die bürger die in
bestimmten der rhetorischen wohnhaft
sind das recht haben ihr eigenes
schicksal zu bestimmen
sie nennen die äußersten mittel also
intervention in der ukraine aber sie
schließen solche invention nicht raus
aber
ruhig sie vielleicht dass deswegen ein
krieg ausbrechen kann und das zweite was
sie auch gesund darum janukowitsch hat
kein befehl erteilt die protestanten
bürger zu beschießen die das waren doch
die ausgebildeten schützen wissen sie es
gibt das meinungen auch unter den themen
die auf der meydan stand das dass die
provokateure man von einer der
oppositionsparteien haben sie soll das
gehört dann müssen sie das genau lesen
das gibt's in
offener zugang
aber wir haben gesehen wie
polizisten gestanden haben und auf die
gruppe geschossen die wurden mit griffin
geschaffen sodass haben wir gesehen wer
diese gegenseitigen befehl erteilt das
weiß ich weiß dass
verordnet die alle polizeieinheiten aus
der hauptstadt zu entfernen er hat mich
angerufen und ich habe ihm gesagt er
soll das nicht macht darf er es wird ein
das chaos ausbrechen anarchie sie müssen
mitleid mit den menschen haben er hat
das trotzdem gemacht und kaum hat er das
gemacht da wurde sofort sein büro
erobert und es und der regierung und das
kann dann eben zu dem chaos das immer
noch weiter
was heißt denn der krieg beunruhigt ist
und das beunruhigt mich nicht weil wir
nicht vorhaben gehen das ukrainische
volk zu kämpfen es gibt ja die
ukrainische armee hören sie doch
aufmerksam zu ich möchte dass ich
eindeutig verstanden werde wenn wir eine
solche entscheidung treffen das werden
wir das lose schuster ukrainische bürger
machen und soll bloß versuchen ein
indischen streitkräfte zu schießen auf
die eigene leute wir werden vor diese
leute stehen sie versuchen die kinder
unter frauen zu schießen ich möchte
diesen mir anschauen diesen befehl
erteilt unsere kollegen in der ukraine
sagen was sozusagen
berg und angeht die situation um diese
einheit immer schlimmer wird es gibt
manche personen die in sich in
krankenhäusern befinden die werden nicht
behandelt werden nicht gefüttert und die
familien fühlen sich bedroht weil sie
eingestellt werden deren wohnungen was
kann russland da machen
bisschen ja das ist eine frage die uns
das sind doch keine
mitarbeiter des russischen
innenministeriums wir haben doch die
situation nicht dort gelingt aber aus
rein humanitären gründen wäre es richtig
unsere rechtsschutz organisationen
wissen wir auch dass
er alleine oder vielleicht mit den
anderen kollegen mit denen gemeinsam er
die vereinbarung vom 21 februar
ausgearbeitet hat mit vertretern von
frankreich deutschland und polen das sie
vielleicht sich an ort und stelle
begeben und sich anschauen was dort mit
diesen mitarbeitern der einheit berkut
stattfindet die stange doch unter
beschuss und sie haben keine die haben
die haben kein gesetz verletzt sie
wurden nur mit feuer auch sozusagen
beschlossen kers befinden sich im
krankenhaus und werde nicht behandelt
das könne sich schwer vorstellen dass
selbst die gefangenen während des
krieges wurden behandelt und auch
gefüttert sie war nicht nur nicht mehr
behandelt sondern auch nicht ernährt und
auch deren gebäude wollte die verwandte
die familien wurden werden umzingelt und
die werbung dort schikaniert ich finde
sie müssen wir sind bereit sie
aufzunehmen in russland zurück
behandlung
das
integrations rat ihnen
vorgeschlagen den botschafter der
vereinigten staaten
zu rufen ja der staatssekretär ist zwar
eine wichtige person aber das ist keine
instanz die die politik bestimmt wir
beobachten erklärungen verschiedene
politiker verschiedene politische kräfte
das ist die äußerste maßnahme wenn es
notwendig sein wird so werden wir das
tun ich möchte das eigentlich nicht
gerne denn ich glaube dass
bei der zusammenarbeit im
internationalen bereich immer
wirtschaftsbereich im bereich der
sicherheit nicht nur russland
interessiert ist mit dem partner seiner
unser partner sind interessiert an der
zusammenarbeit muss es man kann sehr
leicht dieser werkzeuge zerstören aber
es wird sehr schwierig sein sie wieder
aufzubauen hat
russland sich beteiligt am schicksal von
ja noch ob ich wie sehen sie seine
zukunft ach wissen sie es fällt mir sehr
schwer darüber zu sprechen so aufmerksam
habe ich mich damit nicht beschäftigt
ich glaube er hat keine politische
zukunft das habe ich immer auch gesagt
aber was heißt hier wir haben uns mit
seinem schicksal
beschäftigt wir haben das aus
humanitären gründen ihr gemacht der tod
das ist sozusagen das einfachste um den
legitimen präsidenten
um sich der präsident zu entledigen ich
glaube man hätte ihn sonst einfach
beseitigt
es entsteht die frage wofür eigentlich
beachten sie womit begann dieses ganze
so scheint's anderem das war der antrieb
kommen dass die tatsache dass er das
assoziierungsabkommen nicht
unterzeichnet hat heute sieht das wie so
ein humbug aus es ist lächerlich
überrascht darüber heute sprechen möchte
ich sie jetzt
aufmerksam machen er hat doch nicht
darauf verzichten sie das so da er hat
versagt wir haben das analysiert und
haben festgestellt dass china nicht so
aus dass wir unsere nationalen
interessen nicht entspricht wir können
nicht für die bevölkerung die preise für
strom und energieträger start denn unser
bevölkerung ist auch sonst eher schlecht
daran wir können wir nicht das eine das
weiter dass dritte nicht und wir können
nicht unsere
zu russland zerstören denn wir haben
sehr enge kooperation
sie haben
fünf milliarden wird also werden
produkte deren produktion zum beispiel
des maschinenbaus die verkauf nicht sind
den westen alles nach muss man könnte so
etwas doch nicht einfach kaputt machen
kann doch nicht die technischen
standards von europa einführen in der
ukraine nach denen wir gott sei dank ist
es nicht arbeiten bzw
nicht nur sei dank sondern irgendwann
kommen wir das aber das haben wir nicht
also die betriebe werden stillgelegte
arbeitslosgeld wird steil sind er sagt
ich freue mich so
ich habe gesagt lassen zusätzlich
besprechen er hat doch nicht verzichten
das zu unterzeichnen ihr habt doch er
sucht dass dieses dokument noch
zusätzlich besprochen wird und sofort
kam dieser geschichte die hatte etwas
außerhalb der eigenen kompetenz
gehandelt doch der hat gegen keine
kompetenz bestimmungen verletzt das war
einfach der wand und die oppositionelle
kräfte zu unterstützen in den kampf um
die machen darin ist auch nichts
besonderes aber man dürfte doch nichts
zu anarchie das führe nun durch solche
machtergreifung mit waffengewalt damit
das land in diesem chaos landet in dem
sich das land zurzeit befindet ich
glaube dass unsere westlichen partner
und das nicht zum ersten mal über das
mache ich glaube das sind irgendwelche
köpfe in der amerika setzen die
irgendwelche mitarbeiter eines labors
und sie machen irgendwelche versuche
wieso mit ratten durch unser begreifen
sie nicht die folgen deren handlungen
was sie machen wozu sollte man das alles
wo wir können das es gibt absolut keine
erklärungen
dasselbe
trifft auch dann erst dann weiß man wie
janukowitsch
2004 nicht an die macht gelassen haben
sollten die dritte wahl man hat das
politische leben der boden zu eine farce
gemacht ist die verfassung für sie nicht
dass die menschen daran dass der eine
das recht hat und gegen alles zu
verstoßen das heißt dass auch die
anderen dieses recht haben und dann
entsteht das chaos und darin bestätige
war aber die unsere gesellschaft soll
auf den traditionen des respektes
gegenüber dem grundgesetz erfassung
erzogen werden
übrigen gesetze das klappt nicht immer
aber diese handlung wie stadt will dass
das kontraproduktive
sie haben die gründete nicht
die legitimität also gerade das
parlament ist legitim und sind sie der
meinung dass jazyk legitim ist als
ministerpräsident
und wenn sie der meinung sind dass da
probleme mit radikalen elementen gibt
dann diese elemente werden immer stärker
wenn sie einen gegner hat uns zurzeit
ist dieser gegner russland und russische
position dass wir bereit sind die
truppen einzuführen aus dieser sicht ist
es überhaupt sinnvoll
verhandlungen zu führen mit den
gemäßigten kräften der
ukrainischen regierung zum beispiel ist
er den legitimen haben sie jetzt nicht
zugehört ich habe gesagt vor drei jahren
habe ich die regierungsbeauftragte
kontakte auf der regierungsebene wieder
aufzubauen mit den entsprechenden
kollegen aus den entsprechenden
ukrainischen für ministerien und ämtern
damit wie diese beziehungen nicht
unterbrechen und damit wollen wir sie
unterstützen bei der wiederherstellung
oder wirtschaft das ist der direkte
auftrag der regierung mir nachher mit
viel sie befindet sich im kontakt mit
den jugendlichen
der
regierung ist im kontakt mit dem
amtierenden präsidenten
aber alle beziehungen humanitärer
mission andere können wir nur dann
entwickeln wenn die situation sich
normalisiert und nachdem die wahlen des
präsidenten stattgefunden haben
das heißt sie hat erklärt dass die
eigene gaspreise ab april wieder
eingeführt werden gazprom hat sei gesagt
dass man konnte so nicht behauptet
gazprom kommt nichts zu den alten
preisen zurück gazprom möchte nicht die
rabatte
die
über die gesprochen wurde dir solchen
quartalsmäßig eingeführt werden das war
noch vor der akuten phase dieser
ereignisse weiß ich ich kenne das
gazprom und die russische regierung für
ein jahr vereinbart haben dass gazprom
rabatt einführt bis zu
286 dollar pro 1000 kubikmeter und die
russische regierung erteilt die erste
tranche des darlehens kredit das sind 3
milliarden dollar das ist praktisch für
den einkauf dass dieses unter die
ukrainische seite ist bereit die
schulden zu begleichen
diese schulden entstanden seit der
zweiten hälfte des letzten jahres und
dann verpflichten sie sich die
laufenden zahlungen
regelmäßig zu begleichen die schulden
nicht beglichen und die laufenden
zahlungen finden nicht
danken für februar nicht die schulden
begleichen wird die schuld sogar steigen
zurzeit sind das 500
anderthalb milliarden und sie nicht die
schulden begleichen bis in der früh wird
dann wird die summe zwei milliarden
betragen
aber gazprom sagte wir werden so oder so
bekommen sie besuch keine zahlungen dann
wir fixieren nur die schulden dann
lassen sie lassen sie uns doch lieber
die schulden auf der höheren ebene
fixieren aber das ist doch eine einfach
eine geschäftsbasis von gazprom und das
ist verankert
investitionsplan wir haben doch soll und
haben dieser soll und haben werden
geplant und wenn sie nicht
zeitgerecht
ist das für die ein problem
das ist was überhaupt nicht mit den
ereignissen oder grüne verbunden ist
pläne ist nie schön vereinbarung wir
geben ihnen das geld und rabatte lägen
und sie begleichen uns und wir haben
geld gegeben dass rabatte gegeben aber
auf die zahlungen warten wir immer noch
um gazprom sagt natürlich so geht es
nicht weiter
es wurde berichtet dass sie
einverstanden sind mit der mit dem
einsatz eine internationale mission und
mit der gründung einer kontaktgruppe ich
habe gesagt wir haben extra ausgebildete
personen die diese frage prüfen sollen
und sie sollen diese das diskutieren mit
den deutschen kollegen dass es insgesamt
ich habe unseren außenminister
beauftragt und er soll heute oder
gestern heute morgen sich mit dem
außenminister der bundesrepublik
deutschland herrn steinmeier treffen und
die werden diese fragen besprechen
und natürlich jetzt beachtet man
besonders die situation auf der krim
aber wir sehen was auch in anderen
städten
werden russische
fahnen gehisst wie wenden sich an
russland
denke sie reagieren wir nicht ich glaube
eine ganze stunde da spreche ich über
unsere reaktion in manchen fällen das
was jetzt stattfindet ist für mich eine
überraschung konnte geschweige schon ich
werde nicht sagen was ich aber eine
solche reaktion
und unser partner im westen und auch die
sich als macht in kiel bezeichnen haben
sie etwa nicht
vorausgesehen dass das dazu kommt ich
habe den mehrfach gesagt wo zu spalten
sie das land nein die
dies sind also drängen ganz
ganz starke voran und natürlich menschen
die im osten liebe die sich außerhalb
der entscheidung praktisch gelandet im
grunde
verfasst werden und dieser verfassung
ein referendum
bestätigt werden damit alle bürger der
ukraine sehen dass sie sich beteiligen
und das sind prozesse mit prinz burg vor
beeinflussen bei der gestaltung der
wichtigsten grundsätze bei dem aufbau
des eigenen staates aber das geht es
nicht anders soll die selbst und die
ukrainische macht soll das leben sich
damit beschäftigen nach der entstehung
der legitimen gemacht nachdem der wahl
des präsidenten und des neuen parlaments
was all vorgesehen das wird vielleicht
alles statt an deren stelle würde ich
eben zurück kommen uns immer die
verfassung verabschieden und zwar im
zuge eines referendums abstimmung wenn
jemand das gefühl hat dass er
ausgebootet wurde so wird er immer
unzufrieden gewisse braucht ihr das aber
ich werde
werden sich wie die bei ob sie die
wahlen
kommt drauf an wie die wahlen
stattfinden wende die wahl und das war's
im terror stattfinden wie jetzt werden
wir die wahl nicht an jetzt die
reaktion des westens es werden die
paralympischen spiele bald stattfinden
werden diese spiele stattfinden oder ich
glaube das wäre der gipfel des zynismus
jetzt irgendwelche gefahr bei der
durchführung der paralympischen spiele
jetzt
walten lassen wir wissen ja dass das das
sportliche internationale forum menschen
mit
können der ganzen welt zeigen dass sie
einiges können also mehr als manche
menschen ohne
einschränkungen und sie können das durch
ihre errungenschaften im bereich des
sportes zeigen wenn jemand versucht das
zu verhindern
dann bedeutet das nur 1 siege durch das
diese menschen
die solche versuche unternehmen können
dass nichts heilig für die ist nichts
heilig
die taktische möglichkeiten der als
einsatzes der strucken im westen sagt
man dass im falle des einsatzes der
streitkräfte russland geben das
budapester memorandum verstößt
das der ukraine einiges grantig ist es
möglich im falle eines einsatzes ist es
möglich dass die anderen staaten
involviert werde in diesen stunden bevor
wir etwas öffentlich verkünden und bevor
wir etwas tun auch erst recht praktisch
wir denken wir machen uns gedanken
grünliche gedanken und wir versuchen
alle folgen
vorauszusehen und die reaktion aus allem
möglichen spieler vorauszusehen jetzt
was diese verträge angeht die sie
erwähnt haben sind sie vertreter der
agentur
öffentlichen kreise bei ihnen das ist
doch natürlich eine machtergreifung mit
waffengewalt und das ist klar dass das
verfassungswidrig stattgefunden hat das
ist offensichtlich
sie müssen also als diplomat sein sie
werden ein guter diplomat
er hat ausweichend die frage beantworten
wie sehen die primaten wurde die sprache
gegeben damit sie ihre gedanken
das heißt wenn wir sagen dass das
verfassungswidrige stolz ist dann sagt
man uns nein das ist kein
verfassungswidriger uhr schluss dass es
keine machtergreifung mit waffen das ist
eine revolution
und wenn das eine revolution ist jetzt
soll das ist dann fällt es mir schwer
mit manchen experten nicht einverstanden
zu erklären die behaupten dass wenn eine
revolution stattfindet dann entsteht in
einem bestimmten territorium ein neuer
staat so war das nach dem zusammenbruch
des russischen es entstand ein neuer
start und wir mit diesem start nach der
revolution haben wir keine verträge
unterzeichnet die uns verpflichten
sagte
st
das schadet beiden wirtschaften bedeutet
das etwa dass russland
seinerseits
sanktionen einführen wird man sie aber
über gaastra bathe gesprochen aber es
gab doch noch
auf welchen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen
da eigentlich bei der welche risiken
sind sie bereit einzugehen
im prinzip wollten wir auch weitere
schritte prüfen
zur gewährung der weiteren tranchen und
zum weiteren los gekauft unser
obligation aber unsere westlichen
partner bitten muss das nicht sie bitten
uns
gemeinsam zu arbeiten im rahmen des
internationaler währungsfonds
damit die regierung der ukraine
bestimmte notwendige reformen durchführt
zur gesundung der wirtschaft
wollen wir auch weiter arbeiten aber
wir berücksichtigen
dass der ukraine
nichts bezahlt und prüfte gazprom
verschiedene varianten
insgesamt
glaube ich
die
situation
normalisiert wir müssen aber signal den
menschen geben die im osten und süden
der ukraine
wohnen sie sollen sich in sicherheit
fühlen und sollen sich beteiligen am
politischen prozess
sie haben viele male die zukünftigen
legitimen wahlen in der ukraine
es kann dort natürlich wird das volk das
letzte wort ist sie ich habe keine
blasse ahnung keine blöße
aber die bürger haben auch keine blasse
ahnung alle die ich mit denen ich
gesprochen habe die haben sie sind
völlig verwirrt ja ich kann noch nicht
sagen
wichtig sollten sie nach solchen
ereignissen ist es sehr schwer etwas
voraus zu sein krupp ich habe bereits
gesagt da ist bei aller
eigentlich ablehnung eine solche art der
machtergreifung wurden absetzung des
energieteams präsident wurde ich bin
kategorisch nicht einverstanden wie
dieser form so voll ins gesamte und
sorgt für die ukraine als auch für den
postsowjetischen raum insgesamt ich
wiederhole noch meisten das ist doch
sozusagen die rechtskultur wird dabei
nicht den menschen geeignet wenn die
sagen wenn es für einen erlaubt ist dann
ist das für alle und das schlimmste was
für staaten mit unsicheren wirtschaft
und mit nicht
stabile politische struktur werde da
kann alles denken sie an die
truppe wie haben sie handelten sie als
hitler an die macht
die die die römer einheiten truppen
haben ihre rolle gespielt die wurden
zwar anschließend beschädigt aber die
haben gerade gespielt das kann zu
unerwarteten
varianten kommen
zurecht cardinale veränderungen in der
politik verlangen absoluten für religion
wenn sie und neue frische gesichter in
den oberen staffeln der regierung
verlangen damit kann es passieren dass
wir teufel aus einer tabakdose
irgendwelche nationalist oder kleiner
führer herausspringen kann ihre wäsche
einzig sie mit mit dem hakenkreuz und
dass diese gefahr besteht auch
es geht um die frage nachbarn
nachdem politiker bande
muss man mit dem ja man muss mit allen
im kontakte bleiben
außer mit ausschließlichem verbrechern
aber in sonstige war gefragt
gefährlichen situation kann es
tatsächlich ein mensch da nach oben
kommt er diese gefährlichen ansichten
es wurde gesagt dass timoschenko nach
moskau
ach wissen sie wir haben immer ziemlich
erfolgreich mit der regierung der
ukraine zusammen gearbeitet und zwar mit
regierungen von verschiedenen
politischen ansichten zwingen user haben
wir mit coach mal zusammengearbeitet und
auch mit yuko gearbeitet ich als
regierungschef der russischen föderation
auch habe ich mit timoschenko
zusammengearbeitet die besuchte russland
ich habe sie besucht
wir haben verschiedene situationen
miteinander gehabt bei der umsetzung der
gemeinsam
wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit das gab
bestreite aber insgesamt war das eine
konstruktive zusammenarbeit wenn sie
nach russland kommen will bitte aber
zurzeit ist jedoch kein regierungschef
in welcher qualität
sie kommen will weiß ich ich möchte
keine hindernisse geben damit wenn sie
nach russland kommen möchte
wir steht nach ihrer meinung hinter
dieser organisation selbstloses in
deutschland ich habe schon gesagt ich
bin der meinung das wurde gut
vorbereitet es gab natürlich die
kampftruppen
sie gearbeitet haben und in dieser
hinsicht auch die westlichen
ausbilder haben ihre mühe gegeben aber
es wissen sie wenn sie macht sicher und
stark war da könnten keine nationalisten
dieser programme durchführen und es gebe
keine solche ergebnisse die wir jetzt
haben aber dass wir
keine der vergangenen regierungen
um die sorgen der bürger gekümmert wir
haben ihnen russland auch viele ähnliche
probleme die stetig so
pro kopf der bevölkerung beträgt
die hälfte und unserer kriegsveteranen
die bekommen fast eine
durchschnittslohn eines
erhalten das heißt der unterschied im
lebensniveau ist nicht groß darüber
sollte man von vornherein
und natürlich sollte man denn diese
familien und
für diese familien
doch alles menschen es gibt das alles
unsinn es gibt keine generation der und
diese dass viele solcher ukrainischen
politiker nacheinander kamen an denen
die bürger getäuscht machen und sie
wollen frischen gesichter an der macht
sehen
das ist der nährboden
gästen was eben geschehen ist also ich
wiederhole der machtwechsel ist
vielleicht doch notwendig so sieht das
aus und in der ukraine arbeit das heute
nur legitim seien im rahmen der
geltenden verfassung nicht unter
verachtung
wenn sie
also konjunktiv wird in der politik
nicht
nicht benutzt und ich bleibe in diesem
rahmen
die frage
nach dem
ich habe ja noch bis vor zwei tagen
gesehen er war am leben ich wünsche
genannt auch er wird sich erkälten doch
bei der beerdigung denen die die
gerüchte verbreiten er sei tot
können sie was sagen sie wollen vor
anlagen die fehler von janukowitsch
wissen sie ich werde diese frage nicht
beantworten nicht weil ich die antwort
nicht weiß ich bin der meinung das ist
nicht korrekt für ihr zur anfang
haben sie
mitgefühl mit dem neuen
politischen ich habe ganz andere gefühle
stärkekartoffel
mensch der eine solche funktion erfüllt
der trägt solcher pflichten auf seinen
schultern und dieser mensch hat
bürgerrechte und er hat auch einen
pflichten aber in erster linie hat eine
solche meldepflicht bis bald und
sollte den willen der menschen erfüllen
die ihm das land anvertraut haben und
zwar im rahmen des gesetzes und man muss
analysieren ob er alles getan hat was
das gesetz
gab und was ihr was dem mandat seine
wähler entsprachen sie haben gesagt sie
haben kein mitgefühl aber haben andere
gefühle können sie darüber vielleicht
was sagen werden wir unter vier augen
darüber weiter sprechen
sie haben gesagt dass in erster linie
müssen wir unsere position denn
bewohnern im südosten der ukraine klar
machen
müssen unser position kennen wir haben
keine feinde dort die ukraine ist ein
freundschaftliches land wissen sie wie
viele im letzten jahr
aus der ukraine nach russland 3,3
millionen 3 fast drei millionen
wanderten nach russland aus um hier zu
arbeiten und wir sind hier und wissen
wie viel geld sie in die ukraine
überweisen um die eigenen familien zu
unterstützen
das soll so das bitter ausgerechnet
millionen
ausgewandert sie die viel geld sie ihren
familien überweisen und hier empfangen
alle und viele arbeiten bei uns selbst
aus dem westen kennedy sind wir uns alle
gleich die sind für uns alle brüder ich
möchte es wird viel über
süden und osten gesprochen aber auch im
westen gibt es auch
russischsprachige leute deren lage noch
schlechter denn die können überhaupt
nicht die sind da unterdrückende minder
wir gehen davon aus dass die sogenannten
macht die wenn sie ihr anspruch darauf
haben dass sie zivilisiert sind dann
sollen sie die sicherheit ihrer bürger
gewährleisten unabhängig davon wo sie
wohnen und hier werden sie dabei
unterstützen danke